welcome to thick boy fighters let's dive
in
michael chandler vs dustin poirier
appears to be close to being a sure
thing rumors suggests the ufc brass is
looking to book the fight for ufc 281 in
new york's madison square garden both
fighters have recently lost in their
bids to take the lightweight title from
charles oliveira but a win against the
other would firmly put them back in
talks for another title shot chandler
recently spoke with
mmafighting.com's damon martin on a
recent episode of the fighter verse the
writer where he questioned puerto's
desire to fight at the highest level i
wake up every morning thinking about
being a ufc champion i've had one crack
at it dustin's now had a couple cracks
at it he's talked about going up to 170
i think it's hard for him to make the
weight i think he's talked about
retiring he's talked about passion he's
talked about desire does he have it
anymore he's talked about fighting nate
diaz we all know what going after a
fight against nate diaz means it begs
the question does he truly believe he's
one of the best in the world anymore i
think he's one of the best in the world
but he's also had a couple conor fights
he's got a little bit of money in the
bank he's getting older it's hard for
him to make the weight he's talking
about going up to 170. these are
telltale signs that i think this is the
right time for me to fight him and the
wrong time for him to fight me that's no
disrespect against him i want to compete
against him i compete against anybody in
the top five that's going to get me
towards the title shot muhammad usman
won the ultimate fighter season 30 over
the weekend with a vicious knockout of
zack paga in the second round but never
mind that we've got two big boys
a little cheeky left hook
he was out
and he's going crazy look at this man
usman joins his brother kamaru as a
champion of the popular show and the
pair become the first set of brothers to
both win the ultimate fighter the
knockout caught the attention of current
heavyweight champion francis naganu who
tweeted
a new contender was born in the
heavyweight division and personally i
want no business with this man congrats
brother kamaru also reacted on his
brother's win with a tweet and in a
video posted by the ufc's twitter
account
beyond proud congrats
it feels great i mean
you know we're still making history each
and every day first brothers ever to do
this
you know in the history of the sport
that's uh that's something big
you know i think when we're done they're
going to see how monumental our mark is
on the sport
his time now
patty the baddie released a vlog to his
personal youtube account detailing the
events that took place immediately after
his second round submission of jordan
levitt at ufc london among the
highlights were patty and meatball molly
mccann receiving news that rapper drake
would be gifting them both rolexes after
he won big betting on the pair paddy
also doesn't seem to have any plans
slowing down in regards to eating in the
video pimlic shared some of the dishes
he enjoyed on a trip to wales with his
fiancee
we're back in the l post cold we're back
in liverpool since we got back from
london i went to wales for two days with
the missus we eating some nice food had
a few nice breakfasts had a nice roast
it's only made birthdays today and we
ordered the other scrambled these pretty
back unbelievable the chips are just
unbelievable on the breaking lines
nailed them also are the zinger chicken
chipotle baguette unbelievable come home
and i had a little bit of cheesecake for
me very much with some cream and i'd
rather whisper goldie with a glass of
chocolate
dana white's contender series will once
again take place tuesday night and will
feature wrestling star bone nickel in
just his second professional mma bout
nickel a three-time wrestling national
champion out of penn state will take on
zachary borrego in tuesday night's
featured bout borrego 3-0 miss weight by
a pound and a half and will find a
portion of his purse video courtesy of
mma junkie
187 and a half
nick diaz had a peculiar return to the
octagon when he fought robbie lawler
last september and threw in the towel
after being dropped by lawler in the
third round diaz also unexpectedly
needed the bout moved from welterweight
to middleweight now diaz's coach caesar
gracie is bringing to light the
circumstances which led to the
lackluster fight from diaz according to
gracie diaz was fighting with a
seriously injured neck which was the
reason he couldn't cut weight and
appeared to not be 100 percent interview
courtesy of submission radio
so nick he went into that fight and his
neck was pretty messed up robbie's a
great tough fighter and everything and
nick was doing great and then you kind
of see nick kind of just kind of fading
as the fight wore on so two of the discs
had ruptured in his neck before the
fight so he was having numbness of the
hands that's why he didn't make 170. he
fought at 185 because it was impossible
to train he just didn't have any
strength he didn't have what you're used
to the nick d as you know he didn't have
it so we finally were able to go and he
got an operation and he put in the
titanium discs in his neck so he's
feeling great from that right now and
it's like we're getting the old nick
back which is really good so now that
that's happened we're waiting for the
doctors he's got another appointment i
think next month and he should be clear
to start training his hard training
again because right now he can only run
and hit pads and everything but he
definitely wants to fight ufc ref dan
mergliata received criticism over what
many believed to be an early stoppage at
ufc 277 when sergey pavlovic finished
derrick lewis in the first round ufc
president dana white agreed with the
sentiment telling reporters it wasn't
early stoppage it was definitely an
early stoppage when you jump right back
up like that and you're ready to go
listen he was a little rocked but no
more rocked than juliana was three four
times during the fight and she fought
five rounds murgliata made a mistake but
it happens
now ufc bantamweight champion aljamain
sterling is also taking shots at the ref
on his personal youtube channel but less
about the early stoppages and more about
mergliatta as a person but if you look
at him when he's refereeing he's always
like got this like smirk that kind of
seems like i don't say condescending but
it's almost like patronize i don't know
i don't know i just feel like that smirk
i just don't like that he always just
has on this like like he'll stop the
fight and he's kind of like
yeah but you got [ __ ] up
on his podcast bro o'malley sean
o'malley reacted to rumors that jake
paul could be fighting internet
personality andrew tate next paul has
been actively looking for a fight on
social media since his bout with haseem
kramen jr fell through a bout between
paul and tate would bring together two
of the internet's most polarizing
figures logan paul hints at andrew
tavers jake paul next day
um
the way andrew tate hits mitts it's hard
to say entertains hands down for boxing
might not be good against jake paul jake
paul's you know been boxing consistently
over the years setting up his right hand
jabber to the body you know entertains
been smoking cigars [ __ ] [ __ ] and
and hit mitts every once in a while so i
think that would not be a good night for
andrew tate if i had a guest kickboxing
it's different i've never really seen it
take kickbox but it adds a different
element to it looking for more original
mma content check out the rest of thick
boy youtube exclusive interviews opinion
and fight analysis is available weekly
on the shob show food truck diaries and
fight night flashbacks subscribe so you
don't miss any of the action
you